[Interviewer] - Cindy,
Cindy, we've spoken before
but we're going to recap
everything we already talked about.
So, where are you from originally?
You grew up where?
- In Highland Park.
- [Interviewer] Out here in LA?
- Yeah, it's by Eagle Rock.
- [Interviewer] You've
been here a long time.
How many years?
- [Cindy] Like 25 years or something.
- [Interviewer] 25 years
and how old are you now?
- [Cindy] 55.
- [Interviewer] What
brought you here originally?
What were the circumstances that got you--
- Using, coming down here to buy my drugs
and then go back home.
- [Interviewer] And what age were you
when you first got involved in drugs?
- I had just turned 21.
- [Interviewer] So, not a teenager.
- Someone that I started
seeing introduced me to heroin
and I tried it, I didn't
even know nothing about it
and that was the biggest mistake ever.
- [Interviewer] Tell
me what your childhood,
you grew up with one parent, both parents?
- Me and my brother, well,
we lived in Santa Monica
and my mom and my dad
and my brother's younger than me,
just like a regular family.
- [Interviewer] No abuse?
No abuse?
- No, no, my mom and dad,
they were good to us.
My dad used to take us on trips.
We'd go to like Big Bear
or we'd go Lake Isabella.
He was always taking
us places, Zuma Beach,
camping and stuff to the mountains.
We went to Tujunga a lot,
we used to go to Tujunga Canyon a lot.
My dad passed away from cancer in 2010
but they were married
forever, my mom and dad.
- [Interviewer] So, no
events that set you on--
- No, they didn't drink,
well, my dad drank beer,
and smoked cigarettes but
nobody in my family did drugs.
- [Interviewer] Is there any history
of addiction in your family?
- No.
We weren't around it either where we lived
there wasn't like any people around
that I saw to like start
paying attention to it.
- [Interviewer] So, for you at 21,
when you first got involved in drugs,
did it just like kick in and take hold?
- [Cindy] Yeah,
and I was already out of school,
but throughout junior
high and high school,
I still didn't know anything about heroin.
I didn't know anybody
that I hung around with.
I never had any boyfriends that did it.
Places I went, people I saw,
or were around, in my neighborhood,
I didn't know any place that sold it.
You know, it was like, it
just wasn't even thought
of over there, but I knew it was bad.
- [Interviewer] And what
is your drug now, heroin?
Have you ever overdosed?
- [Cindy] No.
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever gotten clean?
- [Cindy] When I would get locked up.
- [Interviewer] When
you ended up in prison
and what did you end up in jail for?
- [Cindy] Usually it was for possession.
(sirens blaring)
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money?
- Well, there's people that help me
and sometimes I'll clean tents
or something to get money
and there's a few people I date, you know?
- [Interviewer] Do you have
only regular customers?
- Yeah, but not always.
- [Interviewer] Sometimes
you'll pick up strangers.
- Yeah, if I have to I have to.
But, usually not.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been doing this a long time.
Do you have any crazy stories?
Things have happened.
It's dangerous.
- Yeah, it is.
Not now, but maybe when
I was first down here
I got in cars a couple of times
where someone pulled a gun on me.
Yeah, but they started out being nice
and then afterwards they put the gun away,
you know, just like to scare me with it,
but no one ever like hurt me or anything.
- [Interviewer] What would you like to see
for yourself the next five years?
Do you imagine a different life for you?
- Yeah, me and my
boyfriend that I was with,
we kind of like haven't been
together for a couple of months
but I kind of thought that was going
to be my last relationship
and he was going to
take me away from here.
I just hope that maybe
we get back together.
He doesn't use and we
lived together, you know,
get away from here
and start like a little business.
- [Interviewer] So, you're sleeping where,
you're not in a tent?
- Yeah, I got a tent, I
have a brand new tent.
My friend bought me a real nice one.
- [Interviewer] You're too
well dressed to (indistinct)
You gotta have something.
- I'm still on the street.
It's not getting any better down here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, so the heroin,
do you actually even
enjoy it, do you think?
- I've been on methadone
now for like three years
but unfortunately I'm not
all the way off of heroin.
I still do it a little bit,
but the methadone does help me.
But, I don't know, I
still do it a little bit.
I think it's just because
I've been doing it
for so long that it's just
part of my way of life.
You know, it's just part of
my routine, my daily routine.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- Yeah, I have two daughters
they're in Berkeley.
- [Interviewer] Do you talk to them?
- I was talking to my big daughter
but she doesn't know everything.
She doesn't know that I'm on the street
or living in a tent because
she wouldn't like it.
She'd be becoming down here
trying to take me away.
She's always trying to help me
and she'll send me money grams and stuff
and she'll ask me, "Mom,
can I send you things?"
And if she doesn't hear
from me for a little while
she gets worried and she thinks--
She's happy because I'm
on the methadone program,
but she doesn't know that I still use.
I haven't told her,
been completely honest with her.
I tell her just so much, you know,
because I'm not trying to hurt her.
She worries about me a lot. (car honking)
And no matter what she still loves me
she doesn't turn her back on me.
She just wants us to
have a good relationship
and she wants to be able
to see me all the time
and us to be like normal.
- [Interviewer] Does
she come to visit you?
- She's tried to
and I back out at the last minute.
I don't know, I get scared, I guess
cause I don't want her to
see me in my addiction.
You know, I just, I can't do it.
I don't know.
And everybody says,
Cindy, "She doesn't care.
"She just wants to see her mom.
"She loves you.
"She doesn't care about nothing else,
"where you live or, you know,
"just let her see her mom.
"Why are you trying to
take that from her?"
But, it's just hard, you know?
Cause I don't know her anymore.
She's already like 27 years old.
She's doing real good.
She's a manager of a yoga studio
and she's massage therapist.
So, she's doing really good.
- [Interviewer] Well,
Cindy thank you for talking
to me again, be careful out there.
- [Cindy] Always a pleasure.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.
- [Cindy] Maybe I won't be here forever
but it just seems like it
cause it's been so long.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.